yeah
thank you can everyone hear me yeah i can't change the slides
oh okay this wasn't my choice
so welcome to build a dinosaur workshop today we and
and a group of crut dino marketing research people we we are going to design and build
the best dinosaur so first thing we need to do is find the best requirements for this dinosaur
does anyone have any ideas what our best dinosaur needs
i can't i can't do anything about this okay
thank you um any more that's that's all it needs
so we have an interactive poll
okay well these are the requirements i came up with earlier we're going to build the biggest scariest
loudest dinosaur there is
in our super high-tech dinosaur lab we have designed built and tested the ultimate dinosaur this is what
we have come up with it meets all of our requirements it is big scary and loud so it's perfect to deploy to the wild
okay let's deploy it oh no it looks like we have not quite got our requirements correct
it doesn't do very well there unfortunately it looks like we need to go back to the drawing board
so it looks like it needs to be a little bit smaller
and be better geared
for
for its environment unfortunately because this is project development a couple hundred million years
have passed
and things are looking a little bit different there are now new competitors
and our dinosaur it's not very well suited for the environment
so back
back at build a dinosaur workshop hq everyone's not very happy they've wasted a lot of time
and money coming up with these failed dinosaurs until one of them has a great idea
what if we build a minimum viable dinosaur it meets the minimum requirements that we want for a dinosaur
and we can build it very quickly why don't we just deploy it straight to the environment
and since it's been a very short time not much has changed so now
we have the best dinosaur
so now we can keep iteratively deploying small incremental changes
so now we can keep it in the environment and we can keep it in the environment and we can keep
it in the environment and we can keep it in the environment and we can keep it in the environment
we can keep it in the environment and we can keep it in the environment and we can keep applying changes to make this dinosaur
specially suited for the environment
back at build a dinosaur workshop hq everyone is very happy because they have the best dinosaur
here at poor swigger we don't build dinosaurs we write code
and we know that our code is very well tested and we know that if our code passes all the tests
it's basically ready for release right yeah
so that is what on the academy we have decided to do whenever we
whenever we write code that passes all of the tests it automatically gets deployed to the gin and juice shop
and we know that we can keep it in the environment and we can keep it in the environment and we can keep it in the environment
one unfortunate side effects is that our team city build chains are a little bit complicated
but this is a price we're willing to pay for following best practices
thank you
so